the state versus Richard Alexander
Murdoch defendant indictment for murder
SC code
16-3-0010
CDR code 0116
guilty verdict signed by the four lady
three two twenty three
docket number
2022-gs-15-00593 the state of South
Carolina county of Colleton in the court
of General Sessions the July term of
2022 the state versus Richard Alexander
Murdoch defendant indictment for murder
SC code
16-3-0010
CDR
code0116 verdict guilty signed by the
four lady
date 3 2 of 23.
docket number
2022-gs
15-00595 the state of South Carolina
county of Colleton Court of General
Sessions July term 2022 the state versus
Richard Alexander Murdock the defendant
indictment for possession of a weapon
during the commission of a violent crime
SC
code-16-23-0490 CDR code
0549 verdict guilty signed by the four
person of the jury date 3-23
docket number 2022
gs-15-00594 the state of South Carolina
county of Colleton Court of General
Sessions July term 2022 the state versus
Richard Alexander Murdoch defendant
indictment for possession of a weapon
during the commission of a violent crime
SC code
16-23-0490
CDR code
0549 verdict guilty signed by the four
person of the jury 3 2 23.
foreign
lady and members of the jury if that is
the verdict of each and every juror
please let it be known by raising your
right hands
all right thank you any individual
polling requested
Madam clerk you'll need to individually
poll the Jew jury according to their
jury
numbers
I'm sorry drawer two five four
is this your verdict yes is it still
your verdict yes there are three two
sticks
was this your verdict yes is it still
your verdict yes juror six juror 530
was this your voted yes is this your
burden yes
sure five four four
was this your verdict yes is it still
your verdict yes
juror 572
was this your verdict yes is it still
your verdict yes juror 578
your verdict yes juror 589
was this your verdict is it still your
verdict
jurors 630
was this your verdict yes is it still
your verdict yes
729 was this your verdict yes is it
still your verdict yes
826. was this your verdict
is it still your verdict
you know stir eight six four
was this your verdict yes is it still
your burden yes
you're honor the jury has been hold
ing thank you the jury has been polled
and the verdict is a unanimous verdict
if you will bring the
alternate juror out and have her have a
seat in the audience please
thank you
you can stand there or you can sit back
there whatever you prefer okay
are there any post-trial motions
the direct converter and at this on on
the grounds those grounds we would
make a motion for a mistrial and to set
aside the burden
by the state response your honor based
on our previous arguments we would
submit that the case properly went to
the jury and the verdict was proper and
would rely on those arguments
we've been here about 28 days
first few days of jury selection and the
remainder
receiving
testimony
a an overwhelming amount of testimony
and evidence that was presented to the
jury for the jury's consideration as I
indicated to the jury doing the jury
charge or the charge on the law that
this was a matter solely for jury the
jury to determine
uh
the court found at the end of the
state's case that there's sufficient
evidence
to find the defendant guilty if the
was believed by the jury
likewise at the end of this the
defense's case when the motion was
renewed the court
um
found that the evidence was sufficient
for the jury to find the defendant
guilty
the jury is now considered the evidence
for a significant period of time
and
the evidence of guilt is overwhelming
and I deny the motion
the Mr Murdock you now having been found
guilty of
two counts of murder involving your wife
and your son
two counts of possession of a weapon
during the commission of a violent crime
the burden now
comes upon the court to impose a
sentence
uh
given the lateness of the hour
and the
victims rights that must be
um
taken into consideration and complied
with under the victim's Bill of Rights
and consider what I anticipate to be a
number of people who might have
something to say regarding sentencing
we will defer sentencing to a later date
of course the
minimum sentence for murder is 30 years
the maximum sentence is life
imprisonment
as to each count
and the
on the weapons charge the sentence is up
to five years
or five years
which has to be concurrent if a life
sentence is imposed
when would you all like to reconvene for
sentencing I would like to give everyone
an adequate opportunity to prepare for
it instead will be ready at 9 30 in the
morning John
we could do it at 9 30 tomorrow morning
also
all right the defendant has remanded to
the custody of the um
Colleton County
Sheriff's Department
and he may be taken away